welcome to the video series of mobile
explained in three minutes where I
explain a concept in molecular biology
in less than three minutes or so today
we'll talk about the mildly tough Mass
spectrometry experiment this measures
the mass of the molecule this is really
useful for peptide identification from a
clinical and a biomedical point of view
this technique is super useful
so if we break the term there are two
important terms in this Mass
spectrometry one is mildy that stands
for Matrix Associated laser desorption
ionization and time of flight which is
also abbreviated as stuff so let's try
to understand what is
Matrix Associated laser desorption it's
a ionization strategy in Mass
spectrometry we need to ionize the
sample and multi is one of that strategy
in time of flight we measured the mass
of the particle so it's kind of like a
mass detection strategy
so let's try to understand multi first
we are looking at the particular
sample plate on the sample plate in blue
you can see these are Matrix molecules
whereas the pinks are the annihilate
molecules laser falls on The Matrix and
it excites particle to get ionized from
this Matrix
so if we look at this process in bit
more details we would understand that
it's it's a soft ionization technique
which does not harm biological molecules
and hence appropriate for biological
sample so here is a laser hitting the
Matrix it would allow
the D's option of annihilate molecules
along with the Matrix molecule metrics
molecule would eventually transfer
protons to it and ionize these
biomolecules once ionized it would be
entering the mass detector for its
analysis now this is a soft ionization
method which is really good for
biological specimen it is cost effective
and easy to perform
now let's try to understand the time of
flight aspect this is a strategy to
detect the mass of the particle
so if we look at the inside part of the
top analyzer we can see here is a matrix
which is localized which is having the
sample just on the top of it there is a
long tube which is known as flight tube
and the end of the flight tube there
would be Mass detector
and in the screen you would see the mass
by charge ratio displayed Whenever there
is a detection happening
so let us break this process and
understand it bit more in bit more
details so let's say the samples are
ionized and
they are entering the mass detector now
depending upon their size the time of
flight would also be different
the particles which were heavy would
take more time to reach the detector
compared to a light particle
and simple
laws of conservation of energy would be
used to understand or derive the mass by
charge ratio let me tell you how these
charged particles would be accelerating
through this tube under the influence of
an electrical field
so imagine the electrical potential
energy for this would be Z times e v
where Z is the charge of the annihilate
molecules e is the
charge of electron and basically V is
the voltage that we apply across this
tube
now kinetic energy of these particles
which are flying would be half MV Square
where Mass denotes denoted by m and V is
the velocity
now as per laws of conservation of
energy these two would equate to each
other
now let's say that tube length is L and
the time of flight is T then the
velocity of the particles would be V
equal to l by T simply distance versus
time
now we can
modulate this equation into z e v equal
to half m
instead of V Square it would be L by T
Square now from this particular equation
if we rearrange it a little bit we would
get the mass by charge ratio M by Z
ratio which would be 2 e v times T by L
now V is the voltage that we apply so we
know the value
L is the length of the tube so it is
fixed and the time of light we analyze
in this detection method and just by
analyzing these parameters we would
understand what is the mass by charge of
the annihilate particle that's the
overall physics behind this particular
technique now let us talk about the
applications of multi it would be used
in biomedical research clinical
diagnosis Pharma industry metabolic
profiling food safety analysis
environmental analysis and many more
there are a lot of advantages and
disadvantages about it for example it is
reliable for Rapid identification of
peptides it is high throughput
it is
easy to prepare the sample for dismas
spectrometry but there are disadvantages
as well because initially the machine
cost a bomb secondly there it requires
skilled operators to operate this
machine for proper functioning
but anyway multi-top is really useful
tool in molecular biology specially for
proteomics metabolomics and
post-translational modifications
you can get more notes and flashcard in
my Facebook Channel follow us in the
Facebook or Instagram all the links are
in the description anyway my handle is
provided as well you can support the
channel using super thanks and see you
in next video